[Music]  countless car is a place to be some  beautiful people lots of great food it's  definitely different than a lot of other  food festivals I'm getting Like Sugar  Rush  it is time  every single inch of the world is here  sort of jammed together I'm so hyped I  just can't wait to see it come together  you get like a little bit of pop some  juiciness some sweetness you know a lot  of viewers they watch cooking videos and  shows they don't get to taste it it's a  way for us to showcase the creative  things the creative ideas that we've  been coming out with whoa this is so  cool the curation of all of the vendors  is pretty amazing oh my gosh the love  for the art and craft of all the things  that we do something artsy something  unique and still true to the dish  foreign